[تصفيق]
نهايه سعيده وبدايه لحياه سعيده للطفل
شنوده الذي عاد اخيرا الى حضن اسرته
بالتبني امال وفاروق بعد رحله معاناه
للطفل والاسره امتدت لاكثر من عام
ما شفتش شنوده النهارده عملت
ايه يا ماما كفايه دي بالدنيا كلها تفتكري
مدام امال ان هو هيحتاج اي حد نفسي يقعد
معه يريحه بصي اكيد اكيد بس انا يعني لو
الكنيسه وكده
وربنا يتدخل بقى ربنا يكمل كان نفسك تشوفي
شنوده فين بيشتغل ايه عايزه شايفه مستقبل
في مخه انه يطلع دكتور كان كل ما حد يساله
يقول له انا اسمي الدكتور شنوده فاروق
وفوزي بولس غبريال اكبر جراح في مصر
العالمي شنوده الذي عثر عليه عام 2018 في
احدى الكنائس تبنته السيده امال وزوجها
وبعد اربع سنوات تقدمت احدى قريبات الوالد
بسبب خلافات حول الميراث ببلاغ كيدي بان
الطفل مختطف ولم يعطر عليه في الكنيسه
الامر الذي ادى الى ايداعه منذ عام في
احدى دور الرعايه ودخول الاسره في اجراءات
قانونيه وق انتهت بصدور فتاوى من الازهر
ودار الافتاء بان الطفل يتبع ديانه الاسره
المسيحيه التي وجدته في الكنيسه وصدور
قرار من النيابه بتسليم الطفل لاسرته
بالتبني طفل ده
كبيره في مصر ان تعدلها هذا الطفل لم تكن
قانون كلمه اسره مؤقته اثار
لان
المفروض اني ان الاسره تنهي اجراءات
الاسره البديله كل هذه الامور قد تستغرق
شهر او شهرين فكانت النيابه العظيمه
المحترمه النيابه العامه يعني لديها من حس
الانساني والحس القانوني وبعد الانساني
قالت لا يعني احنا دلوقتي يقعدوا شهر على
ما يستكملوا الطفل بعيد عن ابوه والقرار
صدر فاحنا هندي مسافه مؤقته وهي بعد كده
تجيب الحاجات دي كلها وبحسب القانون فان
قرار النيابه اسدل الستار على ماساه طفل
لم يتعدى الخمس سنوات ليعود الى حضن الام
والاب بالتبني والذي لم يعرف غيرهما راندا
ابو العزم العربيه القاهره